eight news now continues to tackle the
high rent issue in our valley and one
community often overlooked are seniors
tonight one woman is speaking about her
desperate situation hopes we might find
a solution for her christian cassidus
has the story
margaret mickelberry tells us she was
once homeless but was able to pull
herself out of that situation and into a
one bedroom apartment she says
everything was perfect until her lease
renewal came up with a price hike it's
very stressful i've lost my hair
margaret mickelberry is on a fixed
income and she says it's difficult
her worries are only growing as the days
go by her apartment lease near lake mead
parkway and warm springs is about to
expire in november skyrocketing her nine
hundred dollar rent and moving to a
different location is not in her budget
for one bedrooms and it's supposed to be
seniors fourteen hundred dollars
they've got their income is all they've
got they've come to me and said i've cut
down to one meal a day ron miller is
with hope link of southern nevada a
non-profit organization that he says
aims to help seniors struggling
financially keeping his team busy as
cases continue to go up we will look at
all the possible options to be able to
support their income where it's at
it's not enough
inflation he says is only making things
worse for the senior community many of
them alone with no family support the
organization provides a number of
services and programs but the reality
miller says it's not enough an eviction
happens i honestly i i see some of them
walk along boulder highway here
breaks my heart for this 66 year old she
hopes to find a solution fast to avoid
her past from repeating i was
out on the street mickleberry tells us
she is working with hope link to find an
affordable place to live in the meantime
if you are struggling you can reach out
to hope link or to other resources
available right now on 8newsnow.com
christian casadas 8 news now